satins Creed chronicles delivers a
unique take on the acclaimed franchise
in a 2.5 D action stealth hybrid
platformer the second installment of the
series lets you dive into the mystical
charm of 19th century India during the
height of the British Empire's dominance
the year is 1841 tensions between the
Sikh Empire and the East India Company
have been escalating a rumbling runs
throughout the bustling marketplaces and
heavily guarded Falls ancient cabins and
imperial palaces war is on the horizon
become art as mere Master Assassin you
must navigate through this dangerous and
uncertain time his mission is twofold
he must rescue his love from the
clutches of his sworn enemies and
recover what was stolen from the
Brotherhood
a well-rounded warrior Arbaaz is highly
skilled with weapons and a master of
stealth your greatest weapon is your
ability to move quickly and covertly
hide climb leap and slide your way
through unpredictable surroundings well
fortified fortresses fluid environments
and other obstacles adapt to any
situation thanks to your equipment and
abilities you smoke bomb the noise dawn
even blend of enemies will trick them
using clever disguises our Baz's
signature weapon the unique and
razor-sharp chakram can be used to trick
enemies it also opens new paths for use
to traverse and remain undetected
when pure self is no longer an option
you can switch from silent shadow to
lethal predator taking down enemies with
deadly precision in a blink of an eye
the Swift and powerful tower sword but
pick your open assaults carefully as
public battles catch the attention of
nearby enemies where you risk being
rapidly overrun by attackers no assassin
would be complete without their iconic
hidden blade or in this case our bad and
unique version the Trident blade for
that matter the shotgun can take out
those from a pharmacy feeling creative
look for opportunities to use our versus
weapons and gadgets for the environment
take down multiple enemies at a time or
in one blow both stealthy and the salt
playstyles will earn you XP which can be
used to unlock new abilities and
upgrades to enhance your experience
bonus XP reward if you successfully
complete levels unseen you could always
hone the skills you learned in the
unique designed environments of the
challenge rooms in which your skills and
abilities will be pushed to their limits
for a complex time sequence of obstacle
courses and for an extra challenge you
can also unlock brand new difficulty
modes for a whole new experience
satins Creed chronicles India will be
available digitally on the PlayStation 4
Xbox one and PC sharpen your assassin
skills to this epic setting of episode
of the Assassin's Creed chronicles
trilogy
[Music]
[Music]